فعلا الناس انه خلف العين الاعتبار من بدا
حديث الحرب
ومن كان بيغزوا اوكرانيا المره الاولى في
2014 ومن كان باعتلال القرن منذ هذا الوقت
ومن اليوم يتضرب اماكن مجانيه والمدنيين
المواطنين الاوكرانيين الاطفال والنساء
والمستشفيات والمدارس ما صواريخ الروسيه
كل يوم اجانب الروسي اذن عندهم اسماء هذا
الكلام من الروس فعلا غريب جدا لان نحن
الرئيس وجانب امريكي كنا واضحين من بدايه
هذه الارض ومن قبل بدايه هذه نحن سنقف همم
بجانب الاوكرانيين مع كل همم
كل ما في وسائلنا بتنسيق مع الانتهاء
الاوروبي ولحد الشمال الاطلسي لتقديم
المساعده العسكريه والدفائيه اللازمه
للاوكرانيين اننا ليس الوريد المتحده التي
تعرض هذه العرب من الممكن ان رئيس رئيس
بوتن انها هذه الهربليون اذا هو قام بسحب
قواته من الاراضي الالكترونيه طيب همم قبل
ساعات من زياره كان هناك تصريحات الرئيس
الروسي ابراهيم البوتين قال الناموسكو
ستواصل العام المقبل تطوير قدرته العسكريه
والاستعدادات القطريه لقواتها النوويه كيف
تقراون هذه التصريحات وخاصه توقيت الاعلان
عن همم هذه القرار العسكري
اذا بكل اسف
معنى هذا النوع من الخطاب والكلمات من
الجانب الروسي وهمم كان لدينا الفكره
الواضحه جدا همم منذ شهور وكان البيان
المشترك بين ال- ال- بين الروسيه المتحده
قبل بدايه هذه بان ليس هناك اي فائز من اي
حرب نوويه وليس هناك اي فائده من هذه
القيام وهذه الخطاب حول النوويه اذا
الولايات المتحده الى ان همم كل هذه
الكلام والكتاب همم مزازه للاستقرار وليس
هناك اي حاجه نوع من الخطاب خلال هذه
الحرب الوحشيه من الروسيه طيب نشر صواريخ
بات رؤيه هذا هو الواحد الجديد لاولاد
جديد
سيتم ذلك هل هناك احاديث عن متى سيتم
تدريب يعني المتخصصين الاوكرانيين على ذلك
هل هناك تفاصيل عن حجم هذه الحزمه الجديده
يعني ما الاسباب وراء هذا القرار وكيف
سيتم التطبيق عمليا
الامس نحن سنقدم تقريبا مليار
و850 مليون دولار وهنا جزءا الجزء الاول
من ال ال ال ال الموارد العسكريه لدينا
على الاسلحه والذخائر لدينا واين لدينا
هذه البرنامج الاخرى همم المبادره
للمساعده الاوكرانيه التي نحن نشتري من
القطع الخاص همم بعد دقائق
ربما مرحله جديده في الصراع
كل كل المرحله كل المراحل الجديده في هذا
السرعه تبدا في روسيه تبدا في موسكو تبدا
ما هذه ال ال ال الهجومات ضد المدنيين
والدود الان نحن نرى ان رئيس بوتل وهو
يريد يستعمل حتى فصل الشتاء ضد
الاوكرانيين هو يريد ان ان يمارس عليهم
الجرعه والبرد اذن كل المرحله الجديده
في ماسكا نحن
نقدم المساعده اللازمه للاوكرانيين للدفاع
عن الناس هو منها الان هذه المنظومه
الجديده اللي احنا
وصلنا بسبب هذه الهجومات من الروسيه على
اماكن المدنيه والبنيه التعتيه للطاقه همم
والمياح في اوكرانيا وصلنا الى مرحله
جديده ومن اللازم همم نقوم بالتغيرات في
النوى الاسلحه والنوى المساعده التي نحن
نقدمها
يا محاولات
للمفاوضات مع بوتين
اذا في نهايه المطاف لازم ال ال ال نهايه
هذه الحرب سيكون نهايه عبر الدبلوماسيه
والمفاودات ولكن من اللازم ان ان ان ان ان
ننظر الى الاوكرانيين وليس هناك اي
مفاوضات او اي مناقشه حاول اوكراني وحول
مستقبل اوكرانيا بدون اوكرانيين كما راينا
المراحل رئيس هو يعرف بشكل جيد المستقبل
روسيه وكم الرئيس بوتن يريد ان يفرض
ايراداته الاخرى الورد المتحده لا تعمل
ذلك الولايات المتحده الدعم الجانب
الاخرين في الدعم الشعب
الاردنيانيه ونحن نريد ان نقوم بالتعزيز
امكانيه اوكرانيه
من اللازم الامور شكرا
ناطق الاقليميه باسم وزاره